El Museo Picasso Málaga presenta Picasso es cultor, al igual que en el resto de su creación, la escultura de Picasso se distingue por innovar en el uso de técnicas y materiales pocortodoxos. Puedes imaginar cuáles y como, descubrela. Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The names of several witnesses in this case have been changed.
Melbourne resident Irene Langley was looking through the heraldson newspaper when she came across a job ad for phone sex workers. The customer would ring a 1900 number and he pre-recorded messages from various women. When they heard one they liked, they dial a pin number that directed the call to that particular person. Irene took on the job and had the calls come through to her home phone. After a year in the role, only three calls left her feeling disturbed. One customer told Irene that he'd become sexually aroused while watching his sister shower. Another
expressed a desire to have sex with his own daughter. The third man wanted to speak to an older woman. To appease him, Irene pretended she was 55 years old. In a mean, angry voice, the caller asked, Do you know what I did to the bitch? When Irene asked who, the man responded, My mother, the bitch. He said he'd pressed his hand on her neck before cutting across one of her breasts and slicing through her nipple.
As the man spoke of the blood, his voice became animated and his breathing increased, as though he were aroused. How does that make you feel, he asked. Horrified, Irene ended the call. The man called back shortly after, warning. Listen, don't hang up. I know where you live and who you are. Again, he started talking about attacking a woman, his tone low and hateful.
Irene listened in stunned fear, struggling to take in what the caller was saying. He said he looked into the woman's eyes as he put the steel down her stomach. He didn't say knife specifically, but Irene knew that's what he meant. He didn't say Knife specifically, but Irene knew that's what he meant. She tried to interrupt, but it only made the man angry. He mentioned the blood again, how it had seeped out of the cut nipple and it got on him. He then spoke of, quote, fucking the woman with the blade. Irene could hear his excitement growing and believed he was now masturbating. His description of the mutilation was so vivid, Irene could picture the woman
as a real person. She called him a sick prick and hung up. Irene waited, then picked up the receiver again. The men were still there. Old Kant, he barked, before Irene swiftly pulled the phone's cord from the wall. It was a little after 1pm on Saturday, October 4, 1997, when pensioners Ronald and Immuriel McDonald drove down Clifford's road. The unsealed back road framed the Craigie-Burn railway line on the industrial outskirts of Summerton, a suburb 21km north of Melbourne. The area drew little traffic and was used as an illegal dump site for hard rubbish. The McDonald's often took Clifford's road on their route home, keeping an eye out for any new junk piles to rummage through. Sometimes they
don't cover something worth selling. The couple were joined that day by Muriel's sister, Elaine. The couple were joined that day by Muriel's sister, Elaine. The trio spotted an assortment of computer parts and boxes discarded among the overgrown grass and pulled over to examine the pile. Ronald lived at a sheet of cardboard and exclaimed, oh, what's that? He could see a hint and part of a leg. Muriel thought her husband had exposed a storm Anakin. I don't think so, Ronald replied. He observed rings on the fingers, a bracelet on the wrist, and a tattoo on the leg.
He knew it was a human body. Ronald returned to his car where he had a phone fitted and called the police. Officers arrived and identified the body as a middle aged woman with bleached blonde hair. Her pants and underwear had been pulled down and her blouse and top were pushed up. A large wound was visible on the left side of her chest. There was also
something poking out of the woman's lips. It was a nipple. Her left breast had been removed and stuffed into her mouth. The victim was known to authorities and welfare services. She was 40-year-old Margaret Ma from the neighboring suburb of Craigieburn. Margaret typically lived alone, but her teenage daughter had been staying with her as they endeavoured to bridge a gap that had formed between them. Margaret had lived an ordinary life as a bank worker until she was introduced to heroin. By October 1997, she was a recovering long-term drug user and sex worker. An autopsy concluded that Margaret had been killed elsewhere, then dumped on the side of
Clifford's road in the early hours of the day she was found. She had bruising and stub wounds across her neck, abdomen and limbs, and had sustained a severe blow to the upper right side of her head. Her left wrist had a particularly deep incision, and her neck featured evidence of compression, though her exact cause of death couldn't be ascertained. Margaret's left breast had been mutilated post-mortem by a knife used in a ragged soaring motion. A timeline of her final movements was pieced together. Margaret left home at 7 on the night of Friday, October 3 to visit a local news agency. By the time she returned home, her daughter had gone out and taken the house keys with her,
leaving Margaret locked out. She asked a neighbor for help, but they didn't have the tools needed to get into her house. At around 7.45pm, Margaret was sighted hitchhiking on the nearby Hume Highway. This wasn't unusual as Margaret often relied on her tracking to get around. At 805, she was spotted entering a pharmacy in the nearby suburb of Strathmore, where she bought medication. She then got herself several kilometers north to a shopping complex in broadmeadows. Margaret was a familiar face in the supermarket there and was seen by staff browsing the health, beauty and hygiene aisles before paying for several items. At around midnight, a woman saw Margaret walking through the complex's car park carrying
several shopping bags. She wasn't seen again. It was likely that Margaret crossed paths with her killer as she hitchhiked to each destination. A single black woolen glove found alongside Margaret's body was thought to be the key to solving her murder. It was tested, but limitations in forensic technology prevented any significant discoveries. A 15-minute drive south from where Margaret Mars' body was found is the expansive and serene grounds of Faulkner's cemetery. In the month following Margaret's murder, a woman named Janet Morton visited Faulkner's cemetery to research her family tree.
Janet stood alone in a rose garden examining plaques when she glanced up and noticed the middle aged men on the opposite side of the flower bed. He was short and overweight, with thin, light-colored hair styled in a bowl cart. Janet smiled at the unassuming man, but he ignored her. Janet went to another section where she soon spotted the man again. She then headed to an area 50 feet away, only to realise the man had seemingly followed her there, too. Janet glanced over and met his gaze, realizing then that he'd been watching her. Janet moved on to an older area of the cemetery where she intended to find two particular graves. Her attention was cast downward as she scanned the headstones, when suddenly she heard something to her left.
It was the man. He was moving quickly and intently towards her, with her looking his eyes Janet described as frightening. He got so close that she instinctively put her hand up at him in a stopping motion, and nervously stepped backwards. She ate the screened or yelled, but couldn't remember in the heat of the moment. Whatever she did, it startled the man and he walked away. But he didn't leave. Janet spotted his feet poking out from behind a cluster of trees close by.
Overcome by fear, she turned and ran, leaping over graves until she reached her husband who was waiting in their car. She told him about the encounter and let him to where the man was hiding. He was nowhere to be seen. Janet didn't consider herself to be easily scared, but she was so troubled by the experience
that she gave up on her research and refused to go back to Faulkner's cemetery. Janet was not the only one who encountered this man in October 1997. His behavior revealed a prolonged campaign of harassment during which lone women in fork nacemmetry were watched, stalked, confronted, and chased. Some noted his prescription glasses with thin gold frames. He once donned blue overalls akin to those worn by tradesmen. No one saw him carrying a weapon, though he kept his right hand in his jacket pocket as though hiding something. The women either dismissed the man's actions as misinterpreted and likely harmless,
or chose not to report him out of fear that he was indeed dangerous. On the morning of Saturday, November 1, Limaimer Berman was maintaining the Latvian Memorial section of Faulkner's cemetery when the man approached. Reaking of alcohol, he introduced himself as John Roberts. He kept his hands in his jacket pockets as he engaged Limer in conversation. Twice he motioned to a nearby hedge and asked what was behind it. He then pointed out a nearby grave and said it belonged to his adoptive mother. Lama sensed something unusual about the man.
She felt like he was trying to lead her away. She offered him a rake to tidy the graves side of his adoptive mother and carried on with her work. Later, Lama went by the grave the men had singled out. It remained in an neglected state. Throughout the day, the same men was spotted multiple times. After 3pm, a woman noticed him coming towards her, but he backed off when her boyfriend approached. Shortly before 4pm, the cemetery's mournful silence was shattered
by a woman's sharp and sudden scream. It was coming from the north, where the Greek Orthodox memorial was located. A second scream rang out barely a minute later. The cries decreased in pitch and volume before gradually turning into subdued moaning. The area soon fell silent again. At 6.45pm, Angelo Gorgavski arrived home from work to find his house unusually quiet and empty. His fiance, 25-year-old Messina Halvagas, should have been there. The couple were planning to have dinner out together and Messina was typically reliable, but hours passed with no sign of her.
Angelo was aware that Messina had planned to visit Fork Messimetry earlier that afternoon. Although she didn't like Semitries, Messina visited her grandmother's grave fortnightly to pray, lay flowers, or light a candle. It was still dark at 4.30am when Angelo arrived at the cemetery to see if Messina was there. The grounds were closed, but Messina's locked car was alone in the parking lot. Angelo called the police and escorted officers to the Greek Orthodox section where Missina's grandmother was buried. They wandered down Rhoam and came across Missina Halvaga's not far from her grandmother's grave, lying between two headstones.
She had been stabbed to death in a frenzy attack. The ground around her was covered in blood, as were the surrounding headstones. Flowers scattered across the scene indicated that Messina had been set upon unexpectedly while tending to her grandmother's grave. A chaotic altercation ensued, with Messina's glasses and shoes coming off during the fight. Messina's attacker pulled her upper clothing over her head. The garments remained tangled in her arms and bunched up around her chest, partially exposing her bra. Injuries to Messina's hands showed she'd fought desperately for control of the knife. She endured 85 injuries
in total, including stab wounds to her neck, abdomen and limbs. The killer had zeroed in on Messina's chest and breasts, which featured severe wounds. The crime was particularly disconcerting as Messina had been killed just before 4pm in broad daylight in an inhabited public space. The motive also wasn't abundantly clear. Messina Halvagas, who worked for a bank, was described as selfless and caring. Her family was close-knit, she had no known enemies, and she had an expressed concern for her safety prior to her death.
The killer had likely been covered in blood, yet they only had to run 40 meters to reach the carpark to escape without being seen. Every bush and blade of grass around the crime scene was checked, as well as the Craigbed nearby. All potential clues were thoroughly examined, including several cigarette parts found at the crime scene, and unique tyre tracks in the parking lot. But it was soon realized that Miss Sinus killer hadn't left anything behind that could lead to their identification. Her heartbroken family fronted the press
requesting the public's help. Her father said, every day is nothing but misery in our house. There has to be someone who knows something or suspects something. It's not going to make me feel better, but at least we would know who did it. Visitors to the cemetery on the day of the killing came forward to report what they now
believed was the sound of Messina screaming mid-attack. As none had reported or investigated the screams, the cemetery gates were closed at 8 p.m., with Messina lying dead within. More reports soon came in of the frightening men who distalked women in the week's leading up to Messina's death. Witnesses placed him in the cemetery on the day Messina was targeted, where he had looted for hours. Police were certain he was Messina's killer, and that every other encounter was a
fortunate near-miss. This told detectives that they weren't dealing with an irrational person, but a cold and calculated killer with the presence of mind to stalk and hide. A photo fit of the stalker was publicised and a million dollar reward was offered. fit of the stalker was publicized and a million dollar reward was offered. Six large binders were filled with information pertaining to the Havagas case. Detectives worked 18 hours a day pursuing 400 leads and questioning 1500 people. Several suspects were interviewed, but no charges were laid. Macinus' mother rast herself between sobs. Why? Why us?
What did we ever do to deserve this? Meanwhile, the investigation into the murder of Margaret Ma in Summerton had also gone cold. A year and a half passed with no breakthroughs. Then at 7pm on Monday, April 19, 1999, Rena Hoffman approached the weatherboard cottage rented by her good friend, Nicole Patterson. 28-year-old Nicole worked from home in the suburb of Northcut, a short distance from Melbourne's CBD. The pair had dinner plans that night, but Reena was running late.
She had left a message on Nicole's mobile to let her know, but hadn't heard anything back. Reena parked her car outside Nicole's home on Harper Street and made her way up the driveway, where a light illuminated the veranda. Rina rang the doorbell. Nicole's dog Bella started barking from the backyard, but Nicole didn't appear. Rina rang the doorbell several more times and waited. Rina rang the doorbell several more times and waited. Growing concerned, she forced herself in. Nicole's home was lived in, but tidy. Lights were on throughout, and music was playing from a radio in the lounge room.
Rina headed towards a room at the front of the house, used as Nicole's home office. There, she found Nicole lying on the floor face up in the crucifix position. She was naked from the waist to down, with her underwear looped around one ankle. Her cardigan was pushed up, revealing what appeared to be an orange or yellow top underneath. The carpet around Nicole's body was soaked red, and deep gashes were visible along her wrists. Reena rushed to a phone in the lounge room and called emergency services. The operator instructed her to check if Nicole was still breathing.
Nicole didn't react to Reena's voice or touch. Her skin was cold and her pulse was imperceptible. Reena placed her hand on Nicole's chest to see if she could feel a rising and falling. Nicole's bra was a skew and Reena quickly realized she had been mistaken. Her friend wasn't wearing an orange or yellow top. It was fatty tissue. Nicole's breasts had been removed. The brutal depravity of Nicole Paterson's murder confronted the seasoned homicide detectives
tasked with investigating the crime. She had sustained 27 stab wounds to her back, chest, abdomen and limbs. Further incisions in her thigh, wrists and hands were deemed defensive. There were no signs of forced entry into Nicole's home. The rear door was locked as were all the windows. Nicole's large dog was secured in the backyard, meaning the killer had likely entered from the front. The presence of Mug's and a spilled coffee pot in Nicole's office suggested that she'd
engaged her killer with pleasantries before the attack. She was struck as her back was turned. It couldn't be ascertained with absolute certainty that Nicole had been sexually assaulted. However, what came next was deemed sexually motivated. Once the bulk of the attack was over, Nicole was rolled onto her back. Her top was cut away with scissors and her breasts were removed with a knife in a ragged soaring motion. Nicole's killer then moved throughout her house, leaving blood stains on a hallway wall,
interior door jam, the front door, and inside her bedroom. Nicole's breasts weren't found at the crime scene, indicating the killer might have taken them as a souvenir. Her purse and a driver's license were also missing. Residents along Harper Street were stunned by news of the murder, recalling that Nicole was a lovely and happy young woman. No one had witnessed anyone coming or going from Nicole's home on Monday, April 19, but one neighbor had heard something strange.
They were walking past the Nicole's home just after 9am when they heard a woman yell twice. You fucking can't. She didn't sound angry, just upset. The passer-by assumed it was a domestic argument and carried on, unwilling to pry. Another neighbor named Bruce Thompson lived three doors down from Nicole. He was smoking on his veranda just after 9am when he heard what sounded like an injured woman scream from the direction of Nicole's home. Bruce looked up the street but didn't see anything untoward.
He stayed outside for a little longer just in case. Soon, he spotted a stocky, short-statured man walking intently with his hands in his pockets towards Westgarth Street. They locked eyes and Bruce gave a friendly nod, but the man carried on without responding. Bruce didn't recall seeing any blood on the man which correlated with the crime scene. While Nicole's injuries were extensive, they weren't the type to cause extensive blood splatter. None of her arteries had been nicked and her breasts were removed post-mortem.
Any mild splatter her killer might have received could have been absorbed by his clothing, leaving little visible. Detectives believed the man Bruce had witnessed was Nicole's killer, whose car was likely parked in West Garth Street. Scraps of note paper found next to Nicole's answering machine provided a clue. Scrauled in her handwriting at the top of one page was the name Malcolm. The word depression was written underneath. Nicole was a certified psychotherapist and a youth worker.
Described as someone always willing to help others, she had established a private practice at her home. In an attempt to grow her client base, Nicole advertised her services in the North-Curt Leader newspaper. The weekend before her death, Nicole spoke to her friends and family about the very first client she'd taken on named Malcolm. He'd seen Nicole's newspaper ad and booked a session at her home for 9am the day she was killed. Nicole didn't elaborate out of respect for confidentiality, but she was looking forward to the meeting.
There was evidence that the killer had cleaned up after himself by wiping down surfaces and had scoured the home for clues before fleeing. Detectives knew they were dealing with an experienced defender who knew how to beat the system, yet he'd missed something very important. Nicole's appointment book was hidden under clothing and couch cushions in the lounge room. In it, she had noted her meeting with Malcolm and circled it. Most importantly, she had also jotted down a mobile phone number. The number was traced to a 24-year-old international student named Harbourgunn Coley, locally known as Harry. He told police that he had purchased the number as part of a phone plan in mid-March 1999,
a little over a month before Nicole was killed. It was just after Harry had arrived in Melbourne from India to study a master's of business administration. Harry assured police that the phone had remained in his possession the entire time, and no one else had used it. Detectives placed Harry under covert surveillance to see if he did anything that would elevate him as a suspect. All they determined was that he was a normal,
law-abiding young man. Speaking with Harry again, detectives learned that he'd recently applied for general labor, cleaning, and gardening work. He was given a contact to name to Peter, who told him work would commence in mid-May. Harry provided Peter with his mobile number so that he could be contacted closer to the start date.
Detectives believed Peter had contacted Nicole Patterson under the fake name Malcolm, using Harry's number as his own so that it couldn't be traced back to him. It was a clever and calculated cover-up, but flawed. Phone records from Nicole's landline revealed she had received 15 calls from a number in the lead-up to her fatal meeting. The number was associated with the landline in the suburb of Pasco Vale and registered to a man named Peter Dupasse. us. Case file will be back shortly.
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Case file is sponsored by BetterHelp. How much of your time do you devote to looking after others? Friends, coworkers, partners, kids? You spend so much time getting caught up in what everyone around you needs. But what about what you need for yourself? When we spend all our time looking after our loved ones,
it can leave us feeling stretched, thin and burned out. At CaseFile, we know how important it is to look after your mental health. Therapy is more than just talking about your problems, and it's not just for those who've experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you positive coping skills and show you how to set boundaries. It empowers you to be the best version of yourself while giving you the tools to find more balance in your life, so you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind. As the saying goes, you can't pour from an empty cup. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help a try. It's entirely online and designed to be convenient,
flexible and suited to your schedule. To get started, all you have to do is fill out a brief questionnaire and you'll be matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Find more balance with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com-casefile today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-H-E-L-P.com-casefile. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Three decades earlier, on the afternoon of Thursday, October 3, 1968,
15-year-old Peter Dupasse left his home in the inland suburb of Mount Waverley, Victoria. After a short and purposeful walk, he arrived at his neighbor's house and knocked on their back door. Dupasse was well acquainted with his neighbors and got along well with the man of their house. But he wasn't home that day. Only his wife, 27-year-old Anne accursed was. She was nursing their 5-week-old baby. Anne opened the laundry door to Dupas, who was still wearing his uniform after a day at school. With urgency, Dupas asked to borrow a sharp knife to peel
some potatoes for his mother. After commending him for being a good son, En retrieved a small knife and handed it over. Dupas stood silently with the knife's blade pointed towards En. He then launched himself towards her. Peter, what's wrong, Anne asked frantically, as he forced her to the ground by her hair. The teenager strutled Anne before wordlessly slushing at her hands face and neck, wounded and bloody, Anne desperately tried to grab the knife while begging to be let go. Jupas replied, It's too late in, I can't stop now, they'll lock me up. Losing strength against the determined teen, end screened as loud as she could.
Peter Jupas covered Anne's mouth and knows with the palm of his free hand, then pushed his fingers down her throat to silence her. Just as he began to bash Anne's head against the floor, Dupas went still. As if moving in slow motion, he looked at the knife and turned it towards himself. Anne wriggled away. She had sustained mostly cuts and bruises across her head and knack. There were several deeper wounds to her fingers and face, which would require a couple of stitches at most.
Anne coaxed to Dupasse to hand over the knife. She hid the weapon before returning to Dupasse who broke down in tears and begged her to call the police. In a subsequent police interview, Dupasse offered a no explanation for the attack. He had no criminal history and was described by those who knew him as ordinary. At home, Peter Dupasse's upbringing was reportedly normal. He was treated warmly and lovingly by his taxi driver father and a Tupperware selling mother. They raised Dupasse as an only child, as his two siblings were many years older.
He was spoiled and never beaten. School was a far more hostile and isolating environment. While Peter Dupasse was well regarded by educators for being polite and quiet, his peers found him strange and unfriendly. View took any notice of him and those that did bullied him for being short and overweight. Prominent deposits of fat formed over his pectoral muscles, which, quote, had the appearance of female breasts and led to further insecurities. Dupasse was physically weak and only got into typical school yard scraps, never showing signs of extreme violence.
With few friends and limited social skills, Dupasse's life was dominated by his parents. He felt his mother was overprotective and smothering, as he grappled with feelings of inadequacy brought about by his perfectionist father. Following the teen seemingly out of character attack on Ian Akkursd, the courts concluded that he was, quote, Court in an emotional conflict between the need to conform to the expectations of his parents and the unconscious urges to express his aggression and his developing masculinity. Jupas avoided serious punishment and was instead placed on probation for 18 months and ordered
to undergo psychiatric treatment. When speaking in the immediate aftermath of the attack, he explained, I must have been trying to kill Anne or something. I don't know why I was trying to do this. As far as I'm concerned, there is no reason for me to do anything to her. But, I couldn't help myself. During psychiatric observation, Peter Dupasse was considered a model young man. He seemed caring and helpful and was released from hospital within two weeks. By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D.
By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. By March 1972, 18-year-old D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. D. By March 1972, 18 approached a residence and appeared through a bathroom window. There was a woman shiring inside. Her husband spotted Jupas peeping and a chase in chute. When apprehended, Jupas asserted that he had only been taking a shortcut through the couple's yard to get to his car. He was given a $50 fine. Almost two years later in November 1973, police arrived at the Dupasse home and requested
Peter Dupasse accompany them back to the station. When he asked if the matter would take long, the officers informed him that they were inquiring about a rape. Jupas became flustered. The officers told him, if you are not involved, you have nothing to worry about. Jupas started to cry and told his father, I don't want to go with them. His father asked how his son came to be a suspect in the rape.
Two weeks earlier in the nearby suburb of Mitchum, 23-year-old Caroline Bottom was at home with her 18-month-old son when there was a knock at the front door. It was a man Caroline didn't know. He gestured towards a red car parked on the street with its bonnet up, saying that it had broken down. He asked if he could use Caroline's phone, then remarked that he might be able to fix it himself if she had a screwdriver. As Caroline went to retrieve one, the man entered her home. He pulled out a knife and grabbed Caroline's baby to force her to comply before binding the frightened mother with a cord and violently raping her. In the next fortnight two other women reported incidents
involving a man entering their home after requesting a screwdriver for his broken down car. In the first case, he only stole money and fled. He left the second woman's house abruptly when she said that her husband would be back shortly. Peter Dupasse and his car were positively identified by all three women. The now 21-year-old faced charges for house breaking, house breaking with intent to commit a felony and rape.
The trial judge stated, This was one of the worst rapes that could be imagined. You invaded the sanctity of her home by a false story, relying upon her willingness to help in order to gain admission. You threatened her with a knife, you tied her up with a cord, you struck her, and worst of all, you threatened to harm her baby when she tried to resist. The judge reflected on Jupas' 1968 attack the neighbour Ian Atkhurst, a psychiatric report at the time asserted that Dupasse had lost normal control when becoming overwhelmed by pent-up feelings of sexual needs and aggression.
The judge overseeing Peter Dupasse's rape trial rejected this explanation for his most recent offending, saying, This was no sudden impulse because you must have left home that morning armed with a knife and provided with the cord to bind your victim. Given that Joupas had entered two other women's homes under similar pre-tances, further indicated that he was driven by pre-meditation and not impulse. further indicated that he was driven by premeditation and not impulse. Little could be ascertained from psychiatric examination of Jupas as he wouldn't admit any guilt. It was believed he used denial as a coping mechanism and he was diagnosed with an undefined psychosexual problem.
In a letter to the prosecution, a detective wrote, Peter Dupasse is a very dangerous young person who will continue to offend where females are concerned, and will possibly cause the death of one of his victims if he is not straightened out. Peter Dupasse was found guilty and sentenced to accumulative six-month incarceration for each of the breaking counts, with a further nine years for Caroline's rape. Dupasse remained a placid and compliant prisoner in preparation for his first parole bid. He said he felt certain he wouldn't reaffant, and his supportive parents saw his release as early as possible.
A report by a parole officer revealed that psychiatric treatment for Dupasse's type of personality disorder had been ineffective. Although marking Peta Dupasse as an ongoing threat to the community, the officer recommended he be paroled on the condition that he have a great deal of supervision. Dupasse was released in September 1979, after serving just half of his decade-long sentence. He moved back in with these parents who were now living in the beach side city of Frankston.
Joupas was required to receive outpatient treatment at a psychiatric hospital. He was permitted to come and go as he pleased and to know arrival or departure records were kept. Shortly after Joupas' release at a campsite in the seaside town of McCray, some young girls were bathing in a women's shower block when they spotted a man at the open doorway watching them. One of the girls screamed, causing him to flee. When two more incidents were reported, police conducted a stakeout of the amenities and
caught Peter Dupasse in the act. Although he denied peeping on anyone, he was charged with loitering with intent and offensive behaviour and fined $140. On the night of Friday, November 9, Nina Caden entered a women's toilet block in Frankston. As she went to leave the cubicle, Nina was confronted at knife point by a man wearing a balaclava. He ordered her to do as he said or she'd be killed. The man pushed Nina back into the cubicle and proceeded to rape her. When other people entered the toilet block, the assailant pressed his knife to Nina's
throat to keep her quiet. Two nights later, Erika Daines was walking alone down Car Street, a residential road on the Casp of Frankston CBD. She soon realized a man was following her. Unnerved, E Erica quickened her pace. The man matched her speed. When Erica turned to confront him, he rushed in. That's when she noticed the blue balaclava over his face and the knife in his hand.
Erica ran into the middle of the road and screamed. Her pursuer gestured to her to quieten down, but when Erica continued to yell, he fled. A week later, just after 9pm on November 18, Dorothy Elmore was walking along the Nipian highway in Frankston when she was grabbed from behind. The elderly woman was dragged to a vacant block of land and forced to the ground by a masked man. Don't scream or I'll kill you, he warned as he struttled Dorothy with a knife in hand. He attempted to remove her cardigan, but Dorothy resisted and screamed, prompting her
attacker to run away. Dorothy sustained a knife wound to the left side of her chest that required 14 stitches. The following night, Amanda Foltz was walking along Dandenong Road East, a stretch that ran beside the Frankston railway line when she too was grabbed and dragged to a vacant block of land. Her mask wearing a silent groud as he tried to overpower Amanda, who screamed for attention. The men gave up and fled. Investigations quickly led police to Peter Dupasse, who admitted to carrying out the 10-day spree
of Frankston-based attacks. He said, It's all true, I was going to find a woman to rape. In addition to the knife, Dupasse revealed that he'd also been carrying rope to bind his victims with. He told police. It just comes over me. I can't help myself.
I have had a problem for about six years. I'm glad I got caught. It all started again about two weeks ago. I just find it hard to mix with people and I haven't many friends. I just don't know what to say." Detectives noted that whenever Dupasse spoke with men, he appeared timid and nervous. He avoided eye contact, speaking quietly with his shoulders hunched forward. Doctors believed that the introverted, cowering loner sought power by scaring women.
Dupasse was convicted of assault with intent to rob malicious wounding in decent assault and rape. On the surface, the Pudgey baby faced a non-descript man appeared harmless. But when it came to Peter Dupasse, police quickly learned that looks can be deceiving. They found him deceptive, manipulative and intelligent. He knew when to talk, or when to clam up and deny everything to better his outcome. His offending was growing in number and severity. A report stated, number and severity. A report stated, There is little that can be said in Dupasse's favor. He remains an extremely disturbed immature and dangerous man. His release on parole was a mistake. Yet, the police and prosecution were flawed when Peter Dupasse was sentenced to just six
and a half years jail. They had formed the when Peter Dupasse was sentenced to just six and a half years jail. They had formed the belief that Dupasse could not be rehabilitated and should be kept away from society. Yet, he was released in February 1985 at age 31, after serving his minimum term of five years. Like McCray and Frankston, the town of Blair Gowry is located within an area along Victoria's south-east coast called the Mornington Peninsula. The Peninsula is a popular destination in the warmer months, but it was quiet on Black Ari Beach when 21-year-old Hannah Gadsden arrived on March 3, 1985. Only a few figures were visible in the distance. She reached the water, stripped down to her bathing suit, then went for a short walk. Upon reaching an area of jagged rocks, Hannah passed a shirtless man who was wearing jeans.
It was Peter Dupasse. The rocks are sharp Hannah remarked off handedly as they crossed paths. Dupasse smiled and watched as Hannah returned to her things nearby. He then approached her while saying something about a purple-colored starfish and the poor condition of the surf. As Dupas closed in, he swiftly called his arm around Hannah's throat and pressed a knife against her neck. He warned her not to struggle or he'd heard her.
Dupas ordered Hannah to get down on the sand. She screamed out, but Dupas clasped his hand over her mouth. Hannah saw the knife on the sand beside her and raged out for it. Dupas noticed and told her not to be foolish. He then raped Hannah. When she asked why he was hurting her, Dupasse didn't respond. Afterwards he asked the petrified young woman if she wanted a lift. When she refused, he left.
Two men walking along a beach track soon came across crosshanner, who revealed what had happened. One rushed off in search of the assailant while the other helped Hannah to her car to get help. They soon spotted Peter Dupasse, who was walking along a road, unable to find where he parked his car. He was swiftly apprehended. Dupasse initially claimed the encounter was consensual, but eventually confessed otherwise. He'd only been out of prison for four days.
Dupas offered no explanation for his behavior. He claimed he was enjoying laying back on the beach when he saw Hannah Gadsden and couldn't help himself. He said he knew what he did was wrong, adding, I'm sorry for what happened. Everyone was telling me I'm okay now. I never thought it was going to happen again. I only wanted to live a normal life.
Dupasse was relocated to Frankston Police Station for further processing, where he attempted to take his own life, though police doubted his sincerity. At a trial in June 1985, Jupas pleaded guilty to indecent assault with aggravating circumstances and rape. The judge explained that recidivism rates in cases like his were between 80-90% and that Dupasse was walking around with a loaded time bomb in his pocket. Quote There seems to be a very good chance if you were at large again that some other girl might
suffer in the same way. The judge accepted Peter Dupasse's assertions of remorse, adding, One must have sympathy for you, but the community must also be protected. He slammed the lenient sentence handed to Dupasse previously, saying it was inadequate, and acknowledged that the community would be outraged and apprehensive if Dupas previously, saying it was inadequate, and acknowledged that the community would be outraged and apprehensive if Dupas was a free man. He was sentenced to 12 years imprisonment. He was to serve a minimum that reduces offensive sexual behavior.
Shortly after arriving in prison, Dupasse pantaletta to his parents apologizing for his actions. He blamed his deviancy on vague, extraneous circumstances, saying, the way I feel at the moment and have for ages is that I'm far better off out of it all. I tried, I really tried to work on myself and my problems, but I never felt I was getting anywhere. We'll meet again someday. After writing the letter, Dup passe attempted to take his own life. A psychiatrist described his personality as brittle and concluded that it had taken some considerable time to resolve his issues.
Jou passe's unwillingness to admit the full truth about his offending, hampered rehabilitation efforts. Prescribed to drugs that restricted sexual urges were administered with little success. It was found that he lacked motivation for prolonged treatment, and instead wanted a non-existent quick fix. 52-year-old Grace McConnell was a mental health nurse who came to meet Peter Dupas during his time in the prison psychiatric division. Dupas initially viewed Grace as a motherly figure, given their 16-year age gap. But in time, he became infatuated with her, and eventually admitted to have fallen in love.
He told Grace that she could help him come out of himself, and be a normal person. Up until this point, Grace had only fostered a professional relationship with Dupas. Driven by pity, she became closer to him. When he successfully applied to transfer to another prison in rural Victoria, Grace moved to continue their regular visits, even though she suspected he was isolating her. Jupas made Grace write to him every day and displayed jealousy when she didn't give him her full attention. She came to learn that Dupas had a superiority complex and was a possessive, domineering man.
Grace was surprised when Dupas asked her to marry him. Despite feeling their relationship was more mother and son than husband and wife, Grace agreed to the union. She felt a moral expectation to quote, help Peter become a useful member of the community. They tied the knot in a prison ceremony. Grace never felt any real love towards Peter Dupasse, nor did she believe he felt any for her. She doubted he had
the capability. Instead, she believed he viewed her as a possession, like a piece of furniture. Dupas cited his marriage to Grace when he began plotting his parole bid. He referred to her as a beautiful person who would stop him from sexually offending. He attended programs aimed at preparing inmates to return to society and was even approved for temporary release to work for a library, cemetery, and recycling depot. He also took a vocational training course at a local TAFE institution to retrain himself in fitting and machining work. In reference to Dupasse's sex attacks, a psychiatrist reported,
he believes all of that is behind him since he understands himself better and has become more assertive. By 1992, Peter Dupasse had served 7 out of his twelve-year prison sentence and was granted release. He settled with Grace in the country town of Woodend. The community were unaware of his violent history. Peter gained work as a maintenance manager while Grace became a cleaner. There's was a humble, uneventful life as Dupas spent most of his spare time in front of the television. He had few interests or hobbies and didn't care for anything in particular.
He confided in Grace about his unhappy childhood and how he was teased by his peers for being overweight. His parents kept their home uncomfortably sterile and argued often. Dupas stopped assured of describing his teen years, though mentioned with a hint of bitterness at having once been engaged to a woman who gave the ring back. Grace and Dupas didn't consummate their marriage until he was out of prison, where he felt it was more appropriate. Grace described to their sex life as basic and said she went along with it, out of a sense of responsibility. While Dupas didn't reveal
any deviant sexual proclivities with Grace, had reached the point where she couldn't bear him touching her. She otherwise appreciated that he was an overall well-mannered, even-tempered man, and believed she had successfully reformed him. He didn't lash out when upset, instead he just sit and stare. He got lost in thought often. Then there were the random moments he'd break out in sweats and begin shaking without ever explaining why. Peter Dupasse stayed out of trouble for the 12 months he was no longer under any supervision. On Monday, January 3, 1994, Lucy Ionz was water skiing with a group of friends at Lake
Apalok, an hours drive north of Woodland. Lucy went by herself to a women's toilet block, and while inside, her cubicle door pushed inwards. Lucy pressed her hand against the door, and firmly said no to indicate the cubicle was occupied. A long black handled knife suddenly appeared from around the door. A man wearing a cream-colored balaclava tried to squeeze in. Lucy fought to hold the door shut, but the man managed to slash her left hand. Just turn around, he ordered, while trying to force Lucy to face the wall. Her palm and
two of her fingers were dripping blood. Lucy knew she was about to be raped, but she tried to remain calm as to not aggravate her assailant. I'm very frightened, she said repeatedly. Just tell me what's going on. The man kept the knife close to her face and neck. When Lucy refused to let him push her against the wall, the man grabbed her right arm and dragged her out of the toilet block. His demeanor then abruptly shifted. He let go of Lucy, put both his hands in the air and told her to go before he left. Lucy glimpsed her attacker heading towards a blue Ford station wagon. She alerted her friends and they rushed at the car just as its driver reversed and spat
off. Lucy's friends and fiance gave chase in their own car, eventually meeting up with the blue Ford at around about. It drove on at high speeds before making a sharp left turn onto a dirt road and spinning out of control. When the vehicle came to a stop, the pursuers pulled in front to block it and carefully approached on foot. Upon realizing the driver was unarmed, they grabbed him and forced him out. The police were contacted and the offender taken into custody.
He was identified as Peter Dupasse. A search of his car revealed two makeshift balaclavis, duct tape, condoms, handcuffs, a plastic sheet, and a shovel. There were also three knives, one of which was stained with Lucy Ion's blood. There were traces of her blood on his clothing as well. Dupasse was reluctant to speak to police before contacting a solicitor first. After doing so, he said little else to investigators other than, no comment. Prosecutors were in a difficult position.
There was no doubt about what Dupasse had intended to do to Lucy, yet the evidence didn't support an attempted rape charge. Peter ultimately pleaded guilty to unlawful imprisonment in order to have the more serious charges of kidnapping, assault with a weapon, and in decent assault dropped. Sentencing took place in November 1994. Jupas' criminal history was referred to in court as breathtaking. His most recent attack was deemed calculated. He had watched and waited until Lucy was separated from her friends, concealed his identity, and used a weapon with other equipment at hand. The judge accepted that the crime was sexually
motivated, but clarified. I must punish you only for the offense charged, and not for what I think you were going to do, but did not. Highlighting that the victim was held captive for only a few minutes and was voluntarily released, the judge told Jupas. You acted in such a manner to give rise to at least the hope and perhaps the prospect that realization of the significance of what you are about to do activated your conscience. I cannot therefore preclude' hints of conscience. Jupas was sentenced to three years and a nine months imprisonment. This was a major blow to Victoria Police. A year prior, the state government had passed a controversial law to protect the community
from serial sex offenders. It enabled courts to sentence criminals to indefinite jail terms. However, the law could only be activated in cases where the defendant had committed a so-called serious offense. Unlawful imprisonment fell short as it was considered too minor. A group of parents contacted the parole board urging that Peter Dupasse never be released. Yet, by now, he'd mastered the legal system. Realising that denying his crimes jeopardized his chance of parole, he started admitting to them and seemingly accepting treatment. One council are remained skeptical of Jupas, writing,
through long-term association with various professionals, he has learnt to manipulate any individual who has endeavoured to challenge his offending behaviour, by the way of saying the right things and behaving in a convincing manner in a supervised environment. Despite this and other scathing reports, police were powerless to stop Peter Dupasse. He was granted release again in September 1996 at age 43 after serving his two-year minimum sentence. By this point, he'd spent 17 of his last 20 years in jail for sexual offences. His wife Grace conceded their marriage was over, telling the Sunday herald son newspaper. Peter was two people living inside one shell. One was kind and gentle. The other was pure
evil. Dupasse's parents no longer supported him and had moved into state. He resettled in Melbourne's North, when no one knew of his past. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. When Peter Dupasse was linked to psychotherapists Nicole Patterson through calls made from his home, investigators were certain they had found Nicole's killer. Given his history, it seemed Dupasse had escalated just as police predicted.
They moved quickly and attracted Dupasse to a hotel where they found him playing a slot machine in the gaming room. A glint of surprise appeared on his face when police encircled him. A search of Dupas' clothing revealed nothing of significance, though officers did notice two curved scratches on his left cheek. They looked recent and were the type caused by fingernails. Dupas denied everything. He said he didn't know Nicole Patterson and had never been to Harperstreed in Northcut. When asked about the scratches on his face, Dupas, who was now a self-employed woodworker,
claimed a piece of wood had flung up while he was using a lathe machine tool in his workshop garage. Before participating in any further interviews, Dupasse called his solicitor and a priestied mat while incarcerated. He then resorted to a previous tactic of responding to war questions put to him with no comment. A search of Dupasse's Pasco Vale home was underway. A note attached to the site of his fridge featured the name Harry and the phone number belonging to Indian student Harbourgan Kali that was provided to Nicole Patterson by the mysterious
Malcolm. Also found was a copy of a Harold Sun newspaper dated several days after Nicole Patterson's murder. The front page featured an article on the case titled Psycho Knife Killo. Someone had slashed the accompanying image of Nicole's face. Examination of Dupasse's workshop failed to uncover the lathe he claimed caused the scratches on his face. A bag inside his wheelie bin contained torn-up pieces of newspaper. They had come from the advertising section of the Northcut leader, where Nicole Patterson had advertised her therapy services.
Someone had written Nicole's home address on the page, along with the words Niki, North Cat, Malcolm, 9am, and Mo, believed to be shortened for morning. The other side contained Nicole's home phone and mobile numbers. A handwriting expert concluded that this information was scrawled by Peter Dupasse. Dupasse ultimately admitted to making these notes and placing Nicole's to Nicole Patterson's home. He said he'd found her right in the paper and set up an appointment on the day of her murder to address his gambling and relationship problems. Dupasse confessed to providing Nicole with a fake name and number in panic because he didn't
want his girlfriend to know he was seeking therapy. He claimed that he had second thoughts about the session and rang to cancel. Nicole apparently understood and said, if you need to contact me, contact me. Dupasse insisted that he'd spent the morning doing work, errands and domestic chores, and didn't go near Nicole's home at all. Inside his work shed on the bottom shelf of a cupboard, police found a jacket bundled up with other clothing. Inside one of its pockets was a balaclava. The jacket was also splattered with blood. Testing revealed the blood belonged to both Nicole Patterson and Peter Dupasse.
CCTV footage was obtained from a petrol station that Dupasse had visited shortly before Nicole was killed, confirming he'd been wearing the jacket. Jupas admitted the jacket was his and that he'd worn it the morning Nicole was killed, but denied knowing how her blood got on it. The circumstantial evidence was damning, and as a result, Peter Dupasse was formally charged with Nicole Paterson's murder. He pleaded not guilty and faced trial in August 2000. Homicide detectives had worked diligently to ensure their case was solid. The defense team had limited options, and resorted to insinuating that evidence against their client was planted
by police. They implied that a detective had taken a vial of Nicole Paterson's blood to Jupiter's home and adripped the liquid on his jacket, acclaimed the police denied. A soft spoken Jupiter passed took the stand where he appeared nervous. When asked if he killed Nicole, jupas asserted, no, I did not. He intimated that the evidence against him was just bad luck. The prosecution remarked, and it's just bad luck too, isn't it, that the jacket you say you were probably wearing on that morning happens to have the deceased's blood on it?
Dupasse replied, for me it is, yes. A smile appeared on his face as he accused police of setting him up. Everything else Dupasse admitted to, from hindering identification efforts to destroying evidence, he insisted wasn't done with bad intent. The prosecution worked to prove the impossibility of police planting evidence. Then they had one final question for Dupas.
Where have you hidden your trophies, the breasts you cut off the deceased, her driver's license and her purse? Dupasse replied, I don't know what you're talking about. It took a jury less than three hours to find Peter Dupasse guilty for Nicole Paterson's murder. The judge told him, you regarded Nicole Paterson as murder. The judge told him, You regarded Nicole Paterson as nothing more than prey to being trapped and killed. Her life, youth and personal qualities assumed importance in your mind only by reason of
the sense of satisfaction and power which you experienced in taking them from her. You carried out your crime with remorseless deliberation and after careful manipulation of the situation, in full understanding of the significance of your actions. You are now 47 years with a deeply entrenched desire to engage in sexually violent behavior. You have not responded in anything remotely approaching an appropriate fashion to sentences of imprisonment, psychiatric treatment, or community supervision. Realistically considered, the prospects of your eventual rehabilitation must be regarded as close to hopeless that they can be effectively discounted.
Peter Dupasse was sentenced to life imprisonment without the possibility of parole. Nicole's loved ones had mixed reactions. Her boyfriend wanted Dupasse dead. Nicole's father was just grateful the chapter was closed, while her mother said. It helps to know he's not going to be out there doing it again. If he were to walk free, he would kill again. Victoria police were elated that after 30 years of hurting women, Peter Dupasse would finally spend the rest of his natural life behind bars.
But their work wasn't over yet. They believed he held many more dark secrets. The first centered around the unsolved murder of Margaret Ma in 1997. Her mutilated remains were found on the side of an industrial backroad in Summerton. Following Nicole Paterson's murder, links were drawn back to Margaret. Notably, both women had won or both of their breasts removed. The now-emprisoned Peter Dupasse was interviewed about Margaret Mars' murder. He began shaking.
Detectives asked if he knew Margaret, or if he had attended the same supermarket she had on the night of her murder. They also asked if he owned any gloves, in reference to the single black woolen glove recovered at the crime scene. Dupasse reverted to answering all questions with no comment, though he did agree to have his mouth swabbed for DNA analysis. With technological advancements in forensic testing, the black love from the Mar case was reexamined. Margaret hadn't warned it. Biological mixture of at least two people were detected,
but because they were mixed, it was impossible to confirm who wore the glove at the time of the murder. One of the samples was from a random person police couldn't ascertain. The other was consistent with Peter Dupasse. The clothing Margaret had worn at the time of her murder was also re-examined. Her tops had been cut away with sharp, smooth-bladed scissors, similar to how Nicole Patterson's had been removed. Examination of Dupasse's phone records revealed that at the time of Margaret's murder, he had made multiple calls to phone sex lines. One was traced to Irene Langley.
She never forgot the disturbing call she received around October 1997. She told detectives how the male caller detailed hurting a woman with a knife. Most significantly, he referred to cutting off one of her breasts. A second attempted interviewing Dupasse went nowhere. He remained as tight-lipped as ever. Despite this, he was charged with the murder of Margaret Ma. At trial in July 2004, the prosecution relied on the treatment of Margaret's body in relation to Nicole Patterson.
Quote, We say the cutting of the breasts is so unique as to effectively be a signature, a stamp. In fact, after examining almost 4,000 homicides throughout Australia between 1989 and 2000, the only other case involving breast mutilation was that of Nicole Patterson. While Peter GiuPas didn't take the stand on this occasion, 51 other witnesses did. By the end of proceedings, the jury reached a guilty verdict. The Judge told Jupas, After you murdered Margaret Ma, you left her by the side of the road in a desolate place
as a disgusting display of loathing for the deceased and contempt for her dignity. Not contempt with what you had done to her in life, you robbed her of her dignity in death. Sentencing Jupas would have no practical effect as it was already serving life without parole. Still, the judge insisted that punishing him for Margaret's murder was not futile. By doing so, it vindicated Margaret's rights and those left behind to struggle with the grief and trauma of her murder. For that, Peter Dupasse was handed another life sentence without the possibility of parole. Margaret's loved ones thanked Victoria Police for their efforts to bring her killer justice.
Her brother remarked, Margaret lived her life the way she chose, and no one had the right to take that life from her. Members of Nicole Paterson's family attended the trial as a show of support to Margaret's loved ones. Outside court, Nicole's sister said, It's such a rare evil that comes into this world that's destroyed these women and our lives.
We're just praying that this man is accountable for everything he has done. By the time Peter Dupasse was handed his second life sentence in 2004, police was certain he was also responsible for Messina Halvaga's 1997 murder. Dupasse's grandfather was buried in Forknessemetry, just 128 meters west of where Messina's grandmother lay. Nine women had since come forward to identify Jupas as the men who had harassed them in the cemetery before Messina was struck. One described him as having a unique tear in the right pocket region of his jacket, which matched a blemish on the jacket Jupasse war when he killed Nicole Patterson. He'd also been seen wearing gold-framed eye glasses and blue tradesmen overalls.
Two items that Dupasse was known to wear at the time. In the immediate aftermath of Mercenus Murder, it was discovered that Dupasse had visited a salon to have his hair cut and died, as though to prevent him from being matched to the photofid of the cemetery stalker. Messina's upper clothing had become bunched up and tangled in her arms. Investigators believed this had prevented Jupas from mutilating her like he had his other victims. He couldn't risk the time it would take to remove it and adopted to flee. Questioning Dupasse about Messinus murder was characteristically futile,
as he immediately resorted to his typical no-comment answers. Detectives contacted inmates who were in prison with Peter Dupas, hoping he might have said something incriminating while on the inside. One prisoner, a former high-profile solicitor named Andrew Fraser, was serving time for his role in the importation and trafficking of the commercial quantity of cocaine. Given Fraser's previous employment, detectives assumed he'd refuse working with them and encouraged Dupas to keep quiet. To their surprise, Fraser told detectives,
You had better come and see me. Andrew Fraser provided a full statement in which he detailed his relationship with Peter Dupas. The pair were in protective custody together and were both tasked on guard and duties. They also interacted while watching the prison television. Fraser found Dupas to be quiet, socially inept, suspicious, and introspective. He was reluctant to talk, but when he did, he spoke in disjointed short sentences interspersed by long breaks, as though he censored himself to avoid saying anything he'd regret. Fraser also witnessed a Dupas breaking out in mysterious full-body shakes, sweat, and tears.
In time, Dupas opened up to Fraser as much as he thought the man was capable of. Fraser described Dupas as, the most dangerous and unpredictable person I have ever met. Fraser recalled a group conversation involving himself, Dupasse, and a convicted rapist and a murderer named Raymond Edmonds, better known as Mr. Stinky. Edmonds' crimes are covered in episode 131 of Case File. Edmonds was 20 years into his prison sentence and was telling the others that he had committed a bad offense, regretted it, and was paying the heavy price.
He turned to Dupas and asked, what about you Pete? Dupas went quiet before admitting offhandedly to killing Nicole Patterson. What's done is done, and I have to wear it," he said. One occasion, Andrew Fraser was working in the garden with the Dupasse when he uncovered a makeshift a knife in the dirt. He showed it to Dupasse, who examined it, and began to sweat. A strange expression appeared on his face before he uttered the word Messina. Another time, Fraser observed an inmate approach to pass and say,
you are Peter Dupas. When Dupas confirmed, the man revealed that he was Messina Havagas' cousin. He called Dupas an animal and threatened to kill him when he got the chance. Shaken, Jupas said to Andrew Fraser. How does that count no I did it? When Jupas was charged with Margaret Mars murder, he told Fraser he thought they might charge him with Messina's murder as well. Jupas stressed that no one witnessed the attack. He also remarked that he hadn't left any forensic set forkness symmetry. It was true that Messinus killer hadn't left behind any forensic evidence, but that information
wasn't public at the time. Andrew Fraser Fraser quote, It was clear to me that there was only one way Peter would have known that fact, and that is, he is the killer. Andrew Fraser's statement came with a degree of criticism. There was a million dollar reward on offer in Messina Halvaga's case, and Fraser was given an undisclosed percentage of it. Yet, homicide detectives stressed that this reward was offered months before Fraser rented the case, and that if he were motivated by money, he would have reached out to them,
not the other way around. Following Fraser's statement, detectives questioned Dupas merely as a matter of procedure, though they knew he was unlikely to concede anything. As expected, he kept a dead pen expression and responded no comment to everything. Dupas was informed that a witness had provided a statement as certain he had confessed to Messina how Vargas' murder. For the first time in all their encounters with Dupas, detectives felt he was genuinely shocked. No comment, he responded.
He was then charged with Messina's murder. His legal team tried to argue that he had become so infamous that a fair trial was impossible. The judge disagreed and the trial went ahead in 2007. The defense attempted to pin the crime on Messina's fiance, Angelogor Gewski, though their efforts were in vain. Peter Dupasse was ultimately found guilty for Messina help Argus's murder. The judge told Dupasse, Messina's last actions were typical of her, a fine young woman in a place of peace and beauty,
thinking not of herself but of others, devoted, considerate and good. Then you struck. Just as Messina's presence at the cemetery was typical of her goodness, your presence at the cemetery was typical of your evil. Cunning, predatory and homicidal. She had no chance against your strength, your knife, and your hate. Then, with your bloody knife, you vanished from the scene. But it was your cunning that was to bring you undone. For you left to no forensics at
Faulkner, words which would come back to haunt you. You have no prospects of rehabilitation, none. You do not suffer from any mental illness. Rather, you are a psychopath, motivated by a deeply entrenched, perverted and sadistic hatred of women. A complete contempt for them, and they're right to live. Peter Dupasse was handed his third life sentence. He appealed, but failed. In 2012, he was granted a retrial for Messina Halvaga's murder, only to be found to guilty again. But his story wasn't over.
Authorities believed a Jupas held the answers to more unsolved violent acts, sexual assaults, and murders. In his statement to detectives, prison informant Andrew Fraser wrote of an instance where Dupasse was talking about the murders being pinned on him, and said, I reckon I'm going to end up wearing the old sheeler down to. It seemed Dupasse was referring to 95-year-old Kathleen Downs. Kathleen was stabbed three times and her throat was slit while she lay in bed in a Brunswick nursing home in December 1997, a month after Messina Halvagas was killed.
Kathleen described as a dear lady with a wonderful nature was considered the matriarch of the nursing home. Evidence indicated that her killer had broken into the building in the early hours between routine checks of the residents. Records showed that Peter Dupasse was home when two calls were made to Kathleen's nursing home. One was made in the month before, the other occurred the morning of. Dupasse was questioned about Kathleen's murder in 2013, but he denied any involvement. He assured Andrew Fraser, they will never get me for that.
Yet, Dupasse was ultimately charged with Kathleen's murder and set to go to trial in 2019. By this stage, star witness Andrew Fraser was suffering from spinal cancer and was too unwell to give evidence and withstand cross-examination. As a result, the trial was discontinued. The presiding judge asserted that the decision didn't constitute an acquittal, and that Jupas could be re-indicted on the murder charge at any time. Kathleen Downs' family were disappointed, but understanding and grateful to the police and prosecutors's efforts. Peter Dupasse is also a suspect in the murders of 48-year-old Helen McMahon and 31-year-old
Renita Brunton. The specifics of Helen's murder are withheld by police, though they've established she was violently attacked while some baking in the seaside town of Rai. Helen was killed 16 days before Dupasse raped Hannah Gadsden on a beach 4 kilometres away in Blair Gowry. He denied involvement in Helen McMahon's murder and it was initially thought that he could and have done it as he was technically meant to be imprisoned during this time. Years later, it emerged that he was actually on pre-release the day Helen was targeted. Police believe Helen McMahon could be Jupiter's first murder victim. In November 1993, Reneta Brunton was stabbed to 106 times in a clothing store she operated in
Sunbury. Reneta had been holding informal counseling sessions out the back of her business, and told friends she was meeting a man with a violent sexual history that day. Most of her wounds sent it around her chest. At the time, Peter Dupasse lived less than an hour's drive away in Woodent, where Reneda also resided. He has been unhelpful when inquired about Reneda's death. Questioning Peter Dupasse is described as frustrating.
Even in the face of overwhelming evidence, he denies everything. He then breaks down, and just when it appears as though he is about to confess, he straightens up and denies everything again. According to one detective, getting a clear answer out of Peter Dupasse is like trying to open a locked door without a key. Following his guilty verdict for the murder of Nicole Patterson, Peter Jew Pass was asked by the judge. At a fundamental level as human beings, you present for us the awful, threatening, and unanswerable question. How did you come to be as you are?
Despite years of examination, experts still don't know what exactly motivated Peter Dupasse's crimes. Since his first attack as a 15-year-old, he has been unable or unwilling to provide any rational or honest explanation for his violent outbursts. He hasn't been diagnosed with any psychiatric disorders. The level of planning and rehearsal he undertook prior to committing his crimes is not normally associated with someone in sane.
In calls to saxophone worker Irene Langley, Dupasse described an attack that reflected Margaret Mars murder, but referred to his victim as his mother, indicating there might be some issues there. There are also theories that Dupasse mutilated his victims because of insecurities he might have towards his own feminine-like breasts. In a report tended to the court during the Margaret Mar trial, a forensic psychologist concluded, Jupas attacked women to fulfill fantasies of conquest and control. For Jupas, the actual assault has not lived up to the fantasy which preceded the assault
and is seen at times as disappointing. He does not feel reassured by either his performance or his victim's response and must find another victim, this time the right one. Thus his offensors become quite repetitive. Whatever the truth, Peter Dupasse was an unusual case for the criminal justice system. He was deemed too dangerous to be let out in public, yet too sane to be institutionalized for life. Criticism has been leveled against the judicial system for allowing jupasers' continual release, despite his escalating crimes and concerns expressed by authorities and the community.
The President of Civil Liberties Group, Liberty Victoria, responded to this backlash by stating, neither imprisonment in itself nor parole itself, is going to stop everybody from committing a fancers. What's important to bear in mind is that a person has to be sentenced for the offense that they've committed, and that might mean that somebody gets a sentence that is proportionate for the crime, but it doesn't cure them of the dangerousness or the characteristic that makes them continue to offend. Peter Jupas will remain in prison until he dies.
In a letter he panned during his early days of offending, Jupas wrote, I feel that I'm not fully confident within myself and there is a possibility that I could re-offend I'll later date. I have no desire to be launched like a time bomb back into the community un-cured. Once again, I can't stress how important it is not only to me, but surely the whole community that this doesn't happen, and I'm given the opportunity to work on my problem. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.